on va alors messieurs les corps ne bouge
pas par régine gal est au courant ça va
je veux faire une interview fin du monde
que vous êtes quelqu'un de spécial
mangue et comme on vient de le vaud la
fin du monde alors c'est la fin du monde
michel oui les cordeaux c'est la fin du
monde si vous deviez sauver un livre moi
je prendrais la bible ouais parce que
bon c'est pas abouti mais on peut en
faire plein à partir de la bible donc
c'est très générateur quoi il ya plein
de petites histoires on peut saluer a
beaucoup servi pour refaire des livres à
partir de 1 si vous deviez sauver un
animal bichon frisé le bichon frisé
oui vous aimez les bichons frisés oui
c'est magnifique votre grand mère avait
un bichon frisé baisse et comme c'est un
tout petit chien c'est comme une peluche
c'est toujours un petit mais non ça ça
boit pas beaucoup en blanc pas du tout
n'ont presque pas et ça vous sautent
dessus ça vous laisse en face et hyper
gentil
si vous deviez sauver une idée une idée
aussi je vais être un peu chiant c'est
peut-être les l'idée de la preuve
mathématique
ouais ça c'est bien ça beaucoup c'est ce
voyage nous simplifions ça va question
suivante un disque il y en a trop le
vôtre non non en béton de ses murs ouais
un field peut-être murnau l'aurore ouais
si vous aviez sauver un sexe sofiane ben
moussa sow veut dire se pose même pas
nous drogue
ben moi je dire le tabac ça l'air de
rien mais c'est bien si vous deviez
sauver un homme politique ça serait ti
tiberi qui brille sous moi je sais pas
j'ai rien contre
jamais dire à monsieur moi moi ou bon
honnêtement j'aime bien chevènement mais
désolé j'étais lui un coup de pied comme
un pigeon non j'aime bien chevènement
chevènement ah ouais ouais je trouve
qu'il est courageux bas les jeunes bon
dieu qui l'a sauvé une fois il allait
coûter bientôt si vous écoutez bien on
rallume